at first glance Amazon Prime seems like
an amazing service offered at an
astoundingly low price but in reality
Amazon Prime is actually not that good
of a deal and here's why
starting off Amazon Prime leads to gross
overspending when you buy an Amazon
Prime subscription you start feeling
pressured that if you don't buy stuff
from Amazon you'll be wasting that money
you spent on the subscription and this
is clear in the numbers on average 46%
of Amazon Prime members make a purchase
on Amazon every single week while only
13% of non Prime Amazon shoppers make
weekly purchases now you could say that
this is just Prime members take
advantage of their perks until you take
a look at the conversion rate non Prime
shoppers convert at 13% while Prime
members convert at a mind-boggling 74%
is this members just take advantage of
their perks or are people simply making
impulse purchases all of this leads
Amazon Prime members spending 1,400
dollars per year on average while the
average Amazon shopper only spent $600
clearly the whole extra 800
all on things you would have bought
regardless of having an Amazon Prime
membership
then what about Prime Li how are you
supposed to take advantage of Prime day
well here's the thing about prime date
it's just another day like Black Friday
where Amazon creates illusion of a deal
to try to convince you to buy crap you
don't need you see whenever we buy
something during a sale our brain
releases dopamine and the bigger that
perceived savings the more dopamine that
is released over time this leads to us
associating rewards with sales and often
times we start chasing the reward buying
a product that we don't even need simply
because it's a good deal primed a is
simply a day designed to boost sales for
Amazon in the dry month of July when a
lot of people are on vacation and still
sales away from their competitors if you
are really after a deals just stick to
Black Friday there is a lot more
competition there and you're a much more
likely to get a better deal so in the
end a prime membership well in most
cases lead to a lot of waste of money
from your
and that brings me on to point number
two and the most important point which
is that you aren't saving any money by
getting Prime unless he specifically got
primed to get a more than 120 dollar
deal on primed a on item that you
actually need you're not saving any
money on Prime the average order price
on Amazon for Prime members is 47 to $50
let's just say 47 to estimate
conservatively first of all there is
free shipping for all Prime eligible
products if you simply spend more than
$25 so all of these orders would ship
for free anyways but there is the
argument that you wouldn't get them in
two days well the thing is since our
most of the things you buy on Amazon
aren't necessities and you don't need
them in two days most of the membership
fees go into shipping as most Prime
members don't even use the other
services like instant video or music
streaming in fact 20% of Prime members
only use Prime for shipping benefits and
never use any other features only 10% of
Prime members use other services on
daily basis and even for these customers
is unlikely they are using more than 10
dollars a year to stream content so at
the very least $90 of the subscription
cost is going towards shipping
considering that the average of Prime
members spends $1,400 a month and that
the average order value is 47 dollars
the average prime member makes about 30
orders a year this makes sense as this
evaluates out to an order about every
week and a half if you are paying nine
dollars for prime shipping that's $3 per
order well the thing is you're already
getting free shipping basic order prices
more than $25 so what if Amazon Prime
wasn't an option at the end of your
order if you have the option of free
shipping in three to five business days
or two days shipping for three dollars
would you actually take this offer each
and every time would you actually spend
$3 to have your Apple slice or printer
arrived a couple of days earlier another
thing to keep in mind is that to get the
shipping price of $3 you had to
originally spend $800 more than an on
Prime member
a non-pom member could actually get the
same value of Prime without actually
getting a Prime subscription considering
that the average non Prime members spent
$600 on Amazon with $44 81 cents per
order on average they make around 13
orders per year if they spent seven
dollars and forty four cents for two
days shipping on every single order they
would only end up spending ninety six
dollars and seventy two cents less than
the cost of Prime membership and that
brings me on to my final point getting a
Prime membership often makes people lazy
shoppers they don't compare prices as
often they spend more exclusively on
Amazon and they probably buy more than
they need and all of this is justified
in the name of getting a deal now I'm
not saying Amazon Prime is bad here is
where Amazon Prime would actually be a
great deal if you are very conscious of
what you're buying you still buy over
one thousand dollars a year on Amazon
and if you would spend three dollars on
today shipping every time and if you're
able to avoid getting Netflix or TV
subscription with this combination you
can get more than what you pay for out
of Amazon and get a really great deal
but for most people getting a membership
simply turns into excessive spending and
lazy shopping when it's presented as
free shipping for an entire year
it seems enticing but when you realize
that's basically $3.00 per order most of
you would be much less likely to take on
the offer at least not on most of your
orders in the end if you are thinking
about getting a prime subscription just
make sure making an informed decision on
whether it's worth it for you don't just
get it thinking that since you shop
offer on Amazon you'll really be getting
a great deal because that's simply not
true but that's just what I think if you
like to see more services just like this
one logically analyzed they makes you
subscribe and drop a like but until then
I'm Ari I'll see you guys on the next
one